sans grande surprise ce débat sur
l'économie a vite donné lieu des
attaques entre le bilan économique du
gouvernement conservateur tom en matière
at il raison de dire qu'il n'ya 300000
personnes de plus au chômage aujourd'hui
qu'avant la récession de 2008
vérification faite c'est inexact selon
les plus récentes données c'est plutôt
241 1000 chômeurs de plus qu'il ya sept
ans at-il comme l'affirment justin
trudeau le pire bilan de créations
d'emplois depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
et le pire bilan de croissance
économique depuis la grande dépression
vérification faite c'est vrai dans les
deux cas mais son gouvernement a fait
face à deux récessions dorcel de 2008
2009 qui fut la pire depuis la grande
dépression des années 30
et comparativement aux autres pays
industrialisés
le canada s'en est plutôt bien tiré
arrivant au premier rang du g7 en termes
de croissance économique depuis la
récession de 2008 2009 avec 15,6 pour
cent comparativement très émue pour cent
pour les états unis
thueux arrive deuxième pour la création
d'emplois au cours de la même période
avec 7,4 pour cent
le canada arrive deuxième derrière les
etats-unis avec 8 9% alors que la
discussion a porté sur l'immigration
stephen harper a affirmé que son
gouvernement à augmenter l'immigration
pour motif de réunification familiale de
25% alors que sous les libéraux de jean
chrétien elle a diminué de près de 50%
vérification faite
c'est faux sous stephen harper
l'immigration pour les réunifications
familiales a augmenté de 5% sous jean
chrétien il y a eu effectivement une
baisse de 43%
mais que ce soit jean chrétien ou
stephen harper le nombre absolu de
réunification familiale est resté stable
environ 60 6000 par année au cours des
vingt dernières années ici denis martin
chabot radio canada montréal